(light music)
- As we move forward, as
scientists, as biologists,
the old adage is true:
A picture is worth a thousand words.
So what is that image,
that graph, that graphic,
or even that imagery
that really gets to the core of your idea.
It almost gets to advertising.
You want that image to stick
in your listeners' minds
that both lets them understand
the undeniably complex concept
that you're trying to convey
but also makes it memorable
and developing that skill
to come up with that picture
that is truly worth a thousand words
is going to be the skill
that we will all need
going into the future.
- Creativity plays a role in my life
pretty much every single day
by reminding me not to stop
just because I've reached a setback,
like hitting a wall as
you're moving towards a goal
doesn't have to be the end for that goal.
To me it just means the path to success
isn't gonna be quite as straightforward
as I originally thought.
Like the way around that wall
may require me to climb
over it, or tunnel under it,
or maybe even dig straight through it.
But if I'm creative enough,
I can probably find a way
to get to the other side.
And this plays out for me in the lab
literally every single day.
It fuels a tenacity that
can see you through things
like graduate school, if you
ever choose to go that route.